most good movies are able to thrive on
the strength of a captivating script
dynamic characters Stellar acting and
Innovative directing most master classes
of Cinema do not need to open with a
nice ass shot to catch the viewer's
attention but there are exceptions I am
of course talking about lost in
translations but Smiley can live up to
that too right this is Stacy and she's
the First on our YouTuber account
because she's played by Nikki limo from
totally sketch okay we get it this is
the only way they know how to hold the
viewers attention Stacy is part of a
group of haors from the online
Collective Anonymous who have gotten
together together at Pacific Valley
University in Los Angeles to start a new
viral Trend using the internet they
spread rumors of a killer named Smiley a
man who supposedly spits his eyes shut
and carved himself a permanent smile
with a knife you start a video reach out
with somebody who you don't even know
and you type in I did it for the bolts
three times and then this guy with the
knife appears behind them and what they
don't